people look for the shortcut the hack  the shortcut is a lie the hack doesn't  get you there there is no easy way there  is only disappoint you can't control  other people the only person you can  control is you you have control over  your - I'm nothing but weakness I did  that Nemoto over stupid things I eat the  wrong  I don't sleep enough i procrastinate I  waste time I care too much about stupid  things and not enough about important  things in all those ways I am weak but I  don't accept that  so often the easy path calls us  [Music]  into that moment to give in to  short-term gratification  discipline will not allow that  discipline can seem like your worst  enemy  it is you best for it  disappointed they will make you a better  and stronger and smarter and faster and  healthier than anything else  the most important who will make you  free  discipline equals freedom  [Music]